yeah one of the things that's
interesting to me is a lot of people
talk about the currency element of
Bitcoin right but there's also a income
aspect to it as well and so earlier this
week I wrote this thing a gentleman from
Venezuela all right so he's a lawyer I
got three young kids and about it sounds
like two and a half three years ago he
started to feel some of the economic
pressure he started a business for spare
car parts right and so as he's going
through more and more inflation sitting
and right about the time where he
realizes you know two two and a half
years into his business hey this isn't
gonna work he discovers Bitcoin
cryptocurrency etc and so he's not you
know poor he's not wealthy by American
standards but you know he had a little
bit of money and so he bought a minor s7
and so he starts mining cryptocurrency
right Bitcoin specifically and then he
bought another machine and now his
family literally lives off of the income
that they received from a couple of
these machines and so it's you know as
long as he has electricity and he can
plug that machine in and he's able to
then go from Bitcoin to Fiat you know
he's got an income stream regardless of
the economic situation around them and
when you do the math I think that one of
the interesting parts is he was telling
me that the minimum wage in Venezuela
today is a dollar twenty-five right and
kind of the US currency but as9 is
mining you know 110 130 bucks depending
where the price and difficulty is and so
it's making him wealthy compared to that
country standards you know in in that
you know kind of perspective how do you
think people in those countries will
continue to use cryptocurrency you know
whether it's trading mining etc as a
supplement to income not just as a store
of value sure so I I don't they were the
original vision for you know 21 as I
remember was actually that they were
gonna produce a six that people were
gonna have you know all over the world
it was going to be embedded in their IOT
devices on their phones etc that
everyone would sort of you know latent
ly be you know earning Bitcoin on a
continual basis and that
honestly older all their devices are
going to be able to frictionlessly sort
of transact with each other and a lot of
the original visions for Bitcoin very
much imagined the world expanding in
this way where people would be mining
their own Bitcoin and that miners you
know wouldn't really be industrialized
the way that they were I think that was
a mistake that many and it not a mistake
even but just necessarily something that
early bitcoiners often didn't anticipate
they didn't see the growth of industrial
scale mining operations especially folk
concentrated in China I think that the
the way I think regular people can can
be significantly impacted with Bitcoin
is actually an extension of what's
already happening by the internet where
you know they could live in a regime
with substantial capital controls but so
long as they have sort of unfettered
access to the Internet
either directly or via VPN there's
pretty much nothing preventing them from
earning you know global sort of living
wages so to speak the most the best
example that I can describe here is
actually there recently I bought a
wallet I bought a wallet directly from
someone in Venezuela no not a Bitcoin
long I bought a physical wallet and the
wallet has some significance I have it
in my backpack so I'll show you but the
wallet is made out of both of ours and
in the because that's kind of reflective
of how much the currency is worth and so
I you know I bought it I wanted to
support you know this guy and his family
and now the thing that I've been talking
to him about is setting up a storefront
for him so did he Key's accept Bitcoin
payments directly ship things out
directly because he you know still has
entire freedoms to do that where they
can earn a wage entirely independent of
their financial system yep allows him to
accept Bitcoin directly and so we've
been working on trying to figure out the
best way to get them up and running
there I think that that's what's really
unlocked is is this sort of frictionless
commerce that can take place all over
the world and it's easy to you know
produce commentary and say well you know
transaction fees are 50 cents and it's
really hard to open a lightning channel
nobody's really using lightning Network
yet and there are all these problems but
I think the reality is that if you if
you sort of look at it bottom-up and you
see what how people are using Bitcoin on
the ground and what you know people sort
of psychosocial perception is of it you
know it's it's easier to see how it's
changing people's lives already